at all saints church in king's heath in
birmingham
the congregation gather for the last
sunday service for at least four weeks
for some this is their main source of
social contact
once again about to be denied from them
well
we'll get used to it again won't we
it is the isolation of it like that you
can't go out and meet
people i want to keep active as long as
i can
you know i'm 85 years old and you know i
feel all this sitting about isn't really
doing me any good and you can't keep on
waiting for dust to fall to keep doing
housework
we're certainly able to keep more
effectively socially distance say than
pupils in schools are i think in a time
of national crisis
the opportunity for people to come
together and pray
is something that would be very helpful
whether it's the church
the gym or the local pub there's an
argument why each could remain open
at this time but the government has made
its choice
essential services manufacturing and
education will remain open for
business and once again it's retail and
hospitality
that are going to have to stomach
another hit
cafes and restaurants can still do
takeout
but this coffee shop worker doesn't
expect business to stay open
as a business they wouldn't be making
any money from it
it'd be literally minimum probably about
a few quid every other day
for them to be taken because after wages
and stuff like that it doesn't be a lot
come thursday these non-essential shops
will keep the shutters down
the furlough scheme will be extended
until december
but this phone shop owner says that's
not enough to cover his overheads
like a huge impact to close keep closing
because already we had a
30 customer a week before the pandemic
and now we're getting around a week
seven customers
at the station in business has been so
badly hit by the existing restrictions
furlough
the pubs been running a food bank since
march and the majority of their visitors
are here for that it's almost more
my work is for the food bank than for
the pub
yeah today we've been open since 12
o'clock
and the only people that i've seen is
people to come and pick food up for
their families
yeah so no one's coming for a pint no
they may not be making sunday roasts
here nor any money
but one pub shifting 12 000 free food
parcels since march is testament
to the community spirit here in
birmingham where there is also a weary
acceptance
that here comes the latest installment
of a disastrous year
jason farrell sky news